well the rock first of all I got to tell
you something men you tattooed half
you've got to do movies where a lot of
times you have your shirt off
right and sometimes their period pieces
where you play a guy back you know like
in the Maumee you working something like
that clearly something else might right
now some of us thought that they were
just like paint ons or something that
you wore for the WWE but you've taken
half of your body literally the whole
entire upper half of your body and
tattooed it no it's just it's over my
chest in my arm it's it's a major piece
it is it's very let me see what you did
there
wow that's major how they didn't cover
that can they it's just paying editor
just putting makeup on it's like a it's
like an airbrush right and just stuff
and it covers that completely yeah
completely yeah the thing that takes the
longest is just finding the the makeup
to match my skin tone look yeah but it
doesn't show up on camera at all no not
at all just completely good really takes
about an hour now what is that it's it's
some own tattoo and and some own culture
that tattooing is very big and very
spiritual and it's basically like
everything that's important to you and
like your family your protection of your
family loyalty and things like that and
in Polynesian culture tattooing is very
very big it's unbelievable
so when you're gonna give up the WWE and
do the acting full-time is Vince gonna
let you keep the name the rock I
actually own it you do it was a
conversation you're telling me you went
to Vince McMahon's office specifically
did you tell him it you wanted to talk
about theirs now when Donna I went to
him I talked to him and he knew you know
what I wanted to do after wrestling
because you know I've been able to
accomplish a lot which is which is
always been great for me Vince doesn't
give away anything I know he doesn't
know so I saw you in the movies you were
trying to move away to the Dwayne
Johnson thing no I wasn't I've always
been billed as a rock but over time they
especially this past year it's been a
media thing like they've been they've
been writing and putting out there
Dwayne the rock Johnson - a rock Johnson
but that's not your thing I heard Vince
was making Vince bones a piece of the
movies that you're in because he owns
the name the rock and he owns you
that's what I heard no I know I own the
name the rock and does he still own you
but do you have to still wrestle I do
not what would be the ramifications if
you left wrestling could could Vince
take back the name the rock no no no I
have my name I own my name and all right
and you didn't have to pay for it I did
not have to pay for it it's Vince
gone insane it is really yeah can I be
honest with you I feel that you tell
you're not telling the whole truth hear
that in other words he gave me the name
with the stipulation that you would do X
amount of wrestling matches no no no no
not at all my my contract is up this
year I'm not too sure you're not kinda
you're making tons of dough in the
movies I'm not a nice exposure the
better and you know what I mean you get
a lay back off that there's a whole big
promotion I was like he's going to
wrestle garden that's amazing what do
you know about Vince that we should I
know I could be honest with you it's
just I had the conversation I said this
is what I want to do and this is what I
want okay no you know what he just said
some rowdy man do you ever like take any
acting lessons or anything you just wing
in it no no no I take a lot action
there's a work with a really good acting
coach oh yeah just to help me yeah maybe
you're the new Schwarzenegger can you
believe how good your movie career is
going to me this is unbelievable that's
awesome